-I'm so happy to see you
in person.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-I am so happy to be here again.
Like, one year --
almost two years.
-Yeah, right?
Here's what happened
since I last talked to you.
-Okay.
-Ready for this?
Your song "Tusa" hit one billion
streams on Spotify.
[ Cheers and applause ]
One billion.
Your album "KG0516" went to
number one on the albums charts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right now you're in the middle
of a soldout tour.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, last night
you won another Latin Grammy
for Best Reggaeton Performance!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ah, ah, ah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Have to bring you to Colombia.
Those steps, those steps.
-I don't know if they'll allow
Grandpa into Colombia.
But anyway.
[ Laughter ]
You're obviously from Colombia.
But before that, you also -- you
lived in New York for a while.
-I lived in New York.
You know, like, I came to
New York for one thing.
-What?
-I wanted to stop doing music.
So I moved to New York.
-To stop doing music?
-To stop doing music.
-And then what made you
start doing the music?
-I had to --
I used to live in Baldwin.
So I had to take three buses
and one train
to get to my school
in Manhattan.
And then in the train
all the time,
I was watching, like,
a billboard of music conference.
And it says like,
"Music but in business,"
like in a business point.
So every day I was
in the train like, "Why?
If I want to stop doing music,
I have to see these people
every...day!"
[ Laughter ]
-So you kept seeing music,
music, music every day.
-Yeah.
-And you knew that's a sign.
-I went to Boston and I studied
that and I'm here, you know?
-Look at you now.
Yeah, look at you now.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm back into music
and I'm here again.
-Congrats.
You're on your solo tour.
How does that feel
to have your own tour?
-Like, it's something --
I don't know.
I'm telling my people
all the time, like,
I'm in an airplane mode
because --
it's hard to believe --
When I'm out,
it's hard to believe that
all of those thousand people
are there for me.
It's amazing.
-Oh, yeah.
-And being part of
those people's lives,
it's amazing for me.
We started, like,
selling theaters,
and then it became,
like, so huge,
and people started buying a lot,
so we moved from theaters
to the arenas right now.
So I'm happy.
People, I love you so much
for giving me this amazing
moment in my career!
-Do you look into the crowd
and just see, like,
a sea of blue hair?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
No, yeah.
-That's good.
-You're laughing but it's true.
Like, I go out
and it's like a --
I don't know -- like a big,
blue cloud in the crowd.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-They use wigs and they put,
like, all of my tattoos.
And they have their merch.
It's amazing.
I love that, people.
It's everything.
-Can you explain what
"bichota" is?
-Bichota? Oh, my God. Okay.
I'm going to -- I'm going to
say it because --
I'm going to say it. Bichota.
It's a word that I knew
from Puerto Rican friends.
-Yeah.
-The meaning is "drug dealer,"
"bichote."
It's the head of the drugs.
Okay.
So the word for me -- Okay.
So, the word for me, like,
the meaning was, I know, tough.
But for me, the word,
it's, like, powerful.
So I said, "What about bichota?"
"No bichota, they don't use it.
They use bichote."
"No, I wanted bichota."
I wanted to create a bichota,
but the meaning is going to be,
like, a like a boss bitch girl,
powerful, great...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...amazing,
doing her things by herself,
you know?
-So, bichota -- So you go,
"I'm making a new thing.
I'm making a --"
-Trying.
-And then you put -- You didn't
even try. You succeeded,
because the song became
a giant hit.
-You know what happened
yesterday?
We were in -- I was in
the concert, in my concert.
And I was about to perform
"Bichota."
So, in the ear, my team told me
like, "Hey, Karol.
You just like five minutes
before, you just won the Grammy,
the Latin Grammy for 'Bichota.'"
So I was about to perform
"Bichota"
and I started screaming.
I told all of my people like,
"Hey, now we have a Grammy."
And we performed "Bichota."
It was amazing. Wow, amazing.
-Look at you.
You're doing it all.
You're doing it.
It's all happening.
It's all real!
-I'm happy, happy for that.
-I know you're so young,
but I just want to ask.
Do you want to
just keep doing this?
Do you want to do other things?
You have other interests?
Or is this it?
You like, "No, this is --"
-I don't know.
I have a lot of things that
I want to do in my life.
I just want to push myself
and see, as a woman,
how far I can go in everything.
Like, in business way,
maybe acting.
I'm going to act.
You know, I have a surprise
for my people in January.
I'm going to start, like,
shooting a series for Netflix.
It's not about my life.
It's acting.
Like, I have a character, so I'm
preparing myself for that.
-In January?
-In January.
-[ Gasps ] On Netflix?
Come on, that's what
I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The sky's the limit.
Always good to see you.
Karol G right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, everybody.
Go to karolgmusic.com
for more info on her tour!